DANA HAN-KLEIN: Hi everyone,
welcome to Talks at Google.
Today is my absolute pleasure to
welcome Paul Scheer, David Wain
and Jonathan Stern.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello!
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
PAUL SCHEER: Thank
you for all coming out
from your desks to be here.
JONATHAN STERN: And their
bikes, probably a lot of them
biked here, I think.
PAUL SCHEER: I wish everyone
was on an elliptical here.
I think that would
be really fun.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: We
have a treadmill desks.
PAUL SCHEER: I want all the
audiences to be that way.
Wouldn't that be great?
You go to a movie, but
you also get a workout.
These movies are long!
"Guardians of the Galaxy
2," what was it, two hours,
20 minutes?
Get on a treadmill, work it out!
DAVID WAIN: Not to
mention, I think Hollywood
is riddled with sequelitis.
How many "Rocky"s
are we going to have?
Is he going to do it
when he's an old man?
JONATHAN STERN: Well apparently.
DAVID WAIN: Oh.
JONATHAN STERN:
Apparently, he did.
DAVID WAIN: I guess he did.
PAUL SCHEER: But it was
really well received.
So you shouldn't
feel bad about it.
DAVID WAIN: Forget it.
PAUL SCHEER: I do think
it redeemed itself.
DAVID WAIN: I'd like to drop it.
PAUL SCHEER: OK.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: It's not going
to go on the internet at all.
DAVID WAIN: I just
can't believe people
take time, when they
could just have free time,
and come and share it with
us-- that's really awesome.
PAUL SCHEER: Well maybe
they're not taking free time.
But maybe because
the company is like,
hey, you don't have to
do work if you come watch
these idiots for a little bit.
And they're like, oh, that's
kind of like goofing off,
so they're getting
double free time.
DAVID WAIN: Or maybe
some people have to go,
like it's court-ordered.
PAUL SCHEER: Like,
this is like what
you get when you do a demerit.
Like, if you wore
the wrong thing,
your demerit is, you
have to watch them.
Like, oh these guys?
I want to see the-- I don't
know, the development people
panel.
JONATHAN STERN: I
think you'd probably
be signing a lot of
people up to Gmail
right now if they weren't here.
There's probably 10,000 people
that would have been signed up.
DAVID WAIN: That's what
Google employees generally do,
is sign people up for Gmail.
PAUL SCHEER: Google
employees are
like the new Jehovah Witnesses.
They just come,
knock on your door,
have you heard about Gmail?
Can we sign you up?
Take your credit
card information?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: So you
guys know all about it,
so we don't need
to be here, right?
We can wrap this up!
All right.
PAUL SCHEER: Exactly.
I am getting all my Gmail
delivered now, it's nice.
It's kind of retro now, I
get it in a little package,
I open it up.
JONATHAN STERN: Are any of you
working on the Google rocket
ship?
There must be a rocket ship.
PAUL SCHEER: They can't tell
you that, it's a secret, right?
JONATHAN STERN: I was going
to see if anyone flinched.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: So I'd love
to know, how do you all
know each other?
PAUL SCHEER: Well, I think
that all of our paths
have crossed at different
times, but David and Jon
know each other
probably the longest.
DAVID WAIN: I met
Jon, I don't know--
JONATHAN STERN: All
right, the boring story.
20 years ago, we were both
in an armed robbery together.
David and Michael
Showalter were looking
for a producer of "Wet Hot
American Summer," the movie.
And I walked in the door,
and tried to produce it
and didn't-- until it became
a TV series years later.
But that was the beginning
of a long and fruitful
creative friendship
and partnership
that continues to this day.
And started back in New York.
DAVID WAIN: By the
way, I put you down
as an emergency
contact at the doctor.
JONATHAN STERN: Oh,
great, which doctor?
Kurtz?
DAVID WAIN: Doesn't matter.
PAUL SCHEER: And I met
Jon about six years ago.
I was pitching him a movie
called "Dry Canadian Winter,"
and we met together, and
he was interested at it,
and that's how we got together.
No, but Jon and I met
when he moved out to LA,
and we started working together.
And we've worked together
in many projects.
I think we all started-- we
all are in the comedy scene.
So there's a lot of overlap.
Even if we're not working
directly together,
there is a lot of
overlap in the people
that we use in our crews, to
the people behind the scenes,
to the people in
front of camera.
JONATHAN STERN: A lot of
collaborate-- the three of us,
and other people that could
easily be sitting here today.
Like Rob Corddry,
and Rob Huebel,
who we collaborate a lot with.
DAVID WAIN: You and
I, I don't think
have ever worked as actual
creative partners on anything
big--
PAUL SCHEER: No.
DAVID WAIN: But we've
probably both participated
in dozens and dozens
of the same projects.
PAUL SCHEER: One of my
first things with David
that I remember--
and it lives with me
as a terrible moment
in my life, because I
was a huge fan of "The State."
I thought it was amazing.
And David had this very--
DANA HAN-KLEIN: That's a
good producer, right there.
PAUL SCHEER: And
I loved that show.
And David was doing
this very cool show
in this venue downtown.
It's was Stella,
essentially right?
JONATHAN STERN: Fez.
DAVID WAIN: Yeah, totally.
Fez in New York City, yes.
PAUL SCHEER: So they
were doing this show.
And all the biggest comedians
at that time-- people
that no one knew, but now
everyone knows, like the Louis
CKs and Sarah Silvermans.
Everyone was doing shows down
there, it was so much fun.
And they asked our
group to do a bit.
And we're like, OK,
we can't fuck this up.
We've got to do the best bit.
It was like, me and Rob
Riggle, and Rob Huebel
and a bunch of us.
We were like, all right,
what are we going to do?
And we came up with this
bit, because Blue Man Group
was across the street,
that we were going to be
members of Blue Man Group.
So we painted
ourselves blue, and we
were going to do all
this dumb, weird stuff.
And then we pull a member of
the audience up, who is a plant.
And then we take them backstage,
and we just beat the shit out
of them.
And it becomes this
bloody murder, and all
this other stuff.
So we shot this video.
We were all ready to do
it, and we get up on stage,
and we do our dumb Blue Man,
like throwing marshmallows.
And it's working OK.
It's not great,
but it's working.
And then we pick the audience
member up from the crowd,
and then the video starts.
It's supposed to play, but
there was a malfunction.
And it just never played, and
we didn't know what to do,
because we had no more bits.
So we covered ourselves in
blood for the end of the bit,
waiting.
So then, it was
like, what do we do?
And we just came
out onstage bloody.
But there was no connective
tissue to what happened.
So it was this great bit that
just failed so miserably.
We had no comeback from
just being covered in blood,
and blue.
We just all were at a
bar, like, slightly blue,
with blood under
our fingernails.
Like, oh I hope
they ask us back.
DAVID WAIN: That sounds awful.
Oh no.
PAUL SCHEER: But yeah,
your video projector broke.
DAVID WAIN: Yeah,
sorry about that.
PAUL SCHEER: No problem.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: So one of the
great things about all of you,
is that you guys were all sort
of early adopters of embracing
the digital medium for
distributing comedy.
Your project lists
go on and on and on.
DAVID WAIN: When we did
our "Stella" shorts that
were part of this
thing, that was
a series of shorts-- it
was basically a web series,
but it was on a thing
called comedynet.com
and it was the size of like, a
postcard stamp, was each video.
And this was in 1998
that we started that.
JONATHAN STERN: So,
first web series.
DAVID WAIN: First web series,
I would like to hope to say.
Thank you very much.
PAUL SCHEER: But
then, the way that I
got "Human Giant" or the way
that "Human Giant" came to be,
was because we started
doing shorts downtown.
And we were part of this
bigger collaborative
thing called "Channel 101."
That was in LA, and what you'd
do is make these little pilots.
And every month, the
audience would vote.
And if they liked your
stuff, you came back
and you did another episode.
And we did channel
102, And that's
how "Human Giant" started.
And that was basically
again, it was before YouTube,
this was pre-YouTube.
Because the shorts were
hosted on this weird site,
and it was hard to download them
and find them and everything.
But that's like, how
we kind of all started.
JONATHAN STERN: And then
one of the first web series,
that I was aware of,
was the one David
and I did together, that
you worked on, Dana.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
I did work on it.
JONATHAN STERN: And
right after, Dave and I
had done a movie together called
"The Ten," with Ken Marino,
and it was an indie film.
PAUL SCHEER: Why would
you lead with Ken?
Ken is one of my favorite
people, and hilariously funny.
There's a lot of other people--
you could be like, "The Ten,"
with like--
JONATHAN STERN: Well, he
was-- Ken was a co-writer.
PAUL SCHEER: Oh, got it.
DAVID WAIN: But I mean,
I was thrown, too.
I'm like, there were a
lot of great people in--
JONATHAN STERN: Sure, sure.
Adam Brody, Liev
Schreiber, Paul Rudd.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah, Paul Rudd
you would lead with, probably.
"The Ten," with Paul Rudd,
who is the lead of "The Ten."
JONATHAN STERN: Famke Janssen.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah, another
big person who's in the movie.
JONATHAN STERN: And
after this movie,
that not that many people
actually saw in the movie
theaters, is-- an opportunity
came from a site called "My
Damn Channel"-- which was an
early channel of all-original
web program content-- approached
David and me about doing a web
series about whatever
David wanted.
So surprisingly,
it was about him.
DAVID WAIN: That's right.
Each episode was about
meeting a different girl
and then making out
with her, and then
screwing it up in some way.
JONATHAN STERN: Like life, yeah.
And we ended up ultimately
doing 45 of these things
over the years,
kept on doing them.
But right at the beginning,
we were treating it
like a TV series, a very
low-budget TV series.
And short episodes,
five minutes each.
But for all intents
and purposes,
we were making a TV series
that was going up on the web.
And very quickly, we
discovered that more people
were watching a single
episode of this web series
that we spent a third of a
day shooting than this movie
that we spent a year making.
PAUL SCHEER: Was that the
movie with Ken Marino?
JONATHAN STERN: Ken Marino
co-wrote it, and he was in it.
Corddry was in that, too.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah.
DAVID WAIN: If you
want to see it now,
you go to www.YouTube.com.
JONATHAN STERN: But also, the
movie-- this ties in-- Google
and YouTube are kind
of related, right?
So what ties into that is, it
still didn't really break free.
Back in that time, there
was curators on YouTube
that would decide what the
videos of the day were.
And they put up five or 10
videos of their favorite-- I
don't even know how they
found it, or decided.
PAUL SCHEER: There was only
about 25 videos at that time,
so it's the cap.
JONATHAN STERN: That's right.
We were submitting
videos every week.
PAUL SCHEER: Oh, I remember
that curator thing, yeah,
now that you talk about it--
JONATHAN STERN: And some curator
picked our sixth episode up,
and then it went
through the roof.
We had a million
hits in 24 hours,
and they kept
picking up episodes.
And that's actually what
helped "Wainy Days" take off.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah, and I think
that for a "Human Giant,"
when we first started, it
was a great way--- like,
MTV was like, no, we only
want to host your videos
on our site.
And if the MTV site from
back then, in the early 2000s
to now, is exactly the same.
It is awful.
It is like, the most
unappealing visually, it's
hard to navigate, like, menus.
You feel like, you have to have
two hands trying to open up
menus, like, why'd it go away?
And we were like, no.
We made a very
firm thing, we were
like, we don't want any of
our videos hosted there.
Or if you do host
your videos there,
we want to be able to
put them on YouTube.
And they fought us so hard.
And we basically-- we got
all of our videos on YouTube.
They have now, in
the last four months,
been taken off YouTube for
copyright infringement,
slowly but surely.
But we had made a
deal with Viacom
that we could host our
videos on that site,
because it was really
important for us to get people
to see our videos that way.
We knew that that
was our audience.
And that was a big
thing in the beginning
JONATHAN STERN: So, Dana
complete coincidence,
before she even put
two and two together,
she was a PA back in Brooklyn,
in the early seasons of "Wainy
Days."
PAUL SCHEER: What
episode did you work on?
JONATHAN STERN: Do you
remember the guest stars?
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
Ken was not there.
Kerry Kenney-Silver was at
one of the ones I was at.
JONATHAN STERN: Sure.
You also worked on the very next
web series that I did-- sadly,
David only was a cameo on that
one-- called Horrible People,
created by A.D
Miles, starring him
and Joe Lo Truglio, which was
also on "My Damn Channel."
And that was a 10-episode web
series, five minutes each.
But where it was one
continuous story,
we were treating it-- we
had a one-hour script.
It was basically
a one-hour comedy.
And so then, it was,
how to make a web
series that was not a short
format, but was long format.
And Dana worked on it.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: And
I think the thing
I remember the most is that,
we shot it in what, a weekend?
JONATHAN STERN: Three days.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah,
and we were just like,
stuck in one apartment.
But it was cool
seeing, I think sort
of what you touched
on-- where it's like,
hey OK, we have
this amount of time,
let's collaborate with as
many people as possible.
Dave was there, Joe Lo
Truglio was there-- well,
he was in it-- but it
was just interesting
that you guys were able to
get so many people to appear.
Just because we were shooting it
in such a short amount of time.
PAUL SCHEER:
Basically, everything--
this is what I've
kind of learned now.
In the beginning, you start off
your career, and you're like,
let's get our friends,
we'll do it for cheap.
We'll just do it down and
dirty, and then the big money
will come.
Never.
That big money never comes.
It's still fucking-- you go,
whose favor can I call in?
Who has a house?
How can I shoot this thing?
JONATHAN STERN: But
then, the next one
will lead to something.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah, finally.
I literally just
did a show for FOX.
FOX, the network, FOX,
and it was the same thing!
It's like, all right,
we'll shoot the whole 10
episodes in two weeks.
Like, let's go, you know,
because like, no one gives up
any money.
Gone are the days where like,
"Will and Grace," or something
like that--
DAVID WAIN: They give it
to some people, I think.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah, right.
DAVID WAIN: I'm going on
30 years in this business,
and it's every time, do this
now, for nothing, next time,
woo!
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah.
And your friends are like,
how many favors, dude?
Like, yeah, you start
to be a bad friend.
Like, please, just
one more time.
JONATHAN STERN: Did you ever
think you would say the phrase,
I'm going on 30 years
in this business?
Now you are.
DAVID WAIN: No, and
God bless us all.
PAUL SCHEER: But it does kind
of work out in a cool way.
Like, I just went to
Sundance with a VR short,
and that was the same
kind of mentality.
My friend was like,
hey, we have this guy,
he is making these VR shorts,
you want to come in and do one?
And I didn't think
anything of it.
We just went there, me and
Rob Huebel, in an afternoon.
Shot this dumb, fart
sketch, which is really
pushing the boundaries of VR.
And that's what
I'm always about.
Really getting to the--
JONATHAN STERN: Because
the fart's everywhere.
PAUL SCHEER: Oh, the
fart is-- it's in 360.
You can experience it in
any way that you want.
It really uses technology
to the best way.
But it is--
JONATHAN STERN: Well,
think about-- a fart, just
slash off the F,
and what's left?
Thank you.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah,
it's totally true.
JONATHAN STERN: Continue
that, what you were saying.
PAUL SCHEER: But I
think that we all
are ready to kind of
jump up and do something.
Because the biggest
paychecks, I will
say, that I've ever
gotten, don't often
lead to the most
fulfilling experiences.
And not to say that there
aren't-- but you should be
having fun.
And I think that some people
sometimes are just motivated
by, oh, what about that?
But it's like, if
you're just having
fun, success and those
things come from that.
And also, it's like,
life's too short.
DAVID WAIN: Or you can
be like these people
and be rich, probably.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah, super rich.
We'd be super rich, come
up with a great idea.
DAVID WAIN: And have
fun, I don't know.
JONATHAN STERN: What was
your biggest paycheck?
I mean, not the amount,
but on what job?
PAUL SCHEER: It was for
$175, and-- no, yeah.
JONATHAN STERN: "Fresh Off
The Boat" is probably OK.
PAUL SCHEER: No, "Fresh
Off The Boat" is normal.
I made my first four million
probably on "Best Week Ever,"
talking about "The Bachelor."
I'm pretty sure
that's probably it.
No, but it's like, I
think part of the thing
is, I come from the background
of the UCB Theater, which is
the Upright Citizens Brigade.
And I'd done shows
there for years.
For literally, since
they opened up the doors
and I was still in
college, till this, like,
I'm missing my show
tonight because I'm here.
Ken Marino has performed
at the UCB Theater.
But those shows, we've never
gotten paid for those shows.
But those are the
relationships and the people
that I work with all the time.
It's just fun to
get up and do stuff.
Yeah, there are things
that are for paychecks,
but there are just
things for the love
of doing what you're doing.
And I think that's always
an important distinction.
And it's something I think
we all kind of share.
Just to roll up your sleeves and
just kind of try something out.
And if it works, great.
JONATHAN STERN: I bet you
guys do that kind of thing,
I'm sure, in a different way?
Right?
Yeah.
PAUL SCHEER: There's got to be--
DANA HAN-KLEIN: That's
a resounding yes!
DAVID WAIN: She nodded.
She does things that are for the
joy or the fulfillment of it.
AUDIENCE: We call
it the 20% project.
DAVID WAIN: That's
what I heard about.
Yeah.
PAUL SCHEER: So 20%-- so only
devote 20% of your energy
on it, because it won't
pay off in a big way?
[LAUGHTER]
It's like, 80% of the
time, make us money.
20%, dick around with your
animated Heathcliff or Garfield
cartoon.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: That's
exactly what the project is--
PAUL SCHEER: Virtual
Garfield, you feed him a line,
he'll respond sarcastically.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Coming soon.
PAUL SCHEER: I want
dibs on that idea.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: But it seems
like also a really fun way
to stay creatively challenged.
Because you're not
being constrained by,
OK, you have to have a 23-minute
episode every week for air.
You can do whatever you want.
PAUL SCHEER: I just did
a six second Vine series.
We did the first-ever
animated Vine series
they called "White Ninja."
And I only made 60 of them,
they're all six seconds long.
And they're like, that's it.
I made a fucking
animated Vine series.
That's crazy, six seconds.
Sometimes I just
grunt and it's over.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
That's what she said?
One of the other
things-- I'm sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
I'll put in my notice now!
One of the great things about
the culture of the internet
and being fans of comedy
and stuff like that,
is that you get to sort
of bring projects back.
And I'd love to talk very
quickly about "Wet Hot American
Summer: First Day of Camp."
Because the first film
was successful in it--
it has a huge cult following.
DAVID WAIN: In so much as
that it was not successful.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: But it's
successful in that it
made lots of people happy.
DAVID WAIN: It was
successful if you add on
that thing, that unsuccessful.
Sorry.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: But
you have a chance
to sort of revisit
something, with hopefully
a bit more of a budget this
time, that people really loved.
PAUL SCHEER: I thought you shot
the series before the movie.
DAVID WAIN: Well, it took
place before the movie.
But the secret is--
and I'm saying this
for the first time in public--
we shot it after the movie.
PAUL SCHEER: What?
DAVID WAIN: 15 years.
PAUL SCHEER: Now that's kind
of crazy, because everyone
looked almost identical.
DAVID WAIN: Almost
identical, amazingly.
PAUL SCHEER: Wow, I thought
you had unearthed it,
like no one bought that--
DAVID WAIN: We
pulled it off, Paul,
and I'm glad you didn't notice.
And you were in it, by the way.
PAUL SCHEER: I was in it!
That's the hardest part.
That's the weirdest part.
JONATHAN STERN: Yeah,
how did we get Paul back?
PAUL SCHEER: I thought
I shot that ages ago.
DAVID WAIN: It was before
you lost all that hair.
But yeah, we did do that.
And actually, with adjusted
dollars and realities
of production, it was
actually not really much more
than the original.
And in fact, I calculated
once, in discussing
how we're going to do
it again maybe someday,
that we had to shoot it
actually pound-for-pound.
Much faster than
the original movie.
JONATHAN STERN: But we
had two cameras this time.
DAVID WAIN: We did
have two cameras.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
Less rain this time?
DAVID WAIN: And
less rain, but we
had more cold, because we shot
it in California in the winter.
PAUL SCHEER: It does seem like
there is this ability though,
to kind of go back
and revisit stuff--
that people like
us, when you get
to be in charge of something,
you'd be like, oh yeah,
bring it back.
I mean, "Full
House"-- bringing back
"Full House" is a dumb idea.
But it's also-- that wasn't
the bastion of quality.
I like "Saved By The
Bell," too, but I
don't need to go see it now.
But this is a perfect
example of it.
Like to kind of bring back
something because you have fans
that are people who
grew up on that.
Or people who found that as a
pivotal point in their life.
DAVID WAIN: And for me
though, that was terrifying.
I care about the fans
of the movie so much.
And I'm a fan of it, and so to
go back and open it up again,
and maybe screw it up
or taint the legacy--
I really wanted to make
sure that it was going to--
PAUL SCHEER: You didn't
want to "Rocky" it.
DAVID WAIN: --Do whatever
I could do, yeah,
to deliver to fans what they
want, but also do something
new, and not have a retread.
There's so many pitfalls when
you do something like this.
But we just kind
of tried to keep
the rudder of, do something
that's funny to us today,
and day-by-day, make it as
good as we could make it.
And then the fact
that a lot of people
had such good response to
it made me feel wonderful.
PAUL SCHEER: Kind of funny
too, because I imagine
that there is a large group of
people on Netflix, who probably
watched "The Hunger
Games," and it
was like, if you like Elizabeth
Banks, you'll like this.
And oh!
And I would love to
see those fans, too.
They're like wait,
what is going on?
Just trying to--
DAVID WAIN: What's that new
series with Bradley Cooper?
Yeah.
PAUL SCHEER: But it
seems like this time,
the show got such a great
kinf-- of all the fans
really got behind it, too.
DAVID WAIN: Yeah,
well I loved also,
the retro con of the press,
where they're like the big,
unanimously supported hit
movie "Wet Hot American Summer"
is back.
And it's like, wait a minute,
no one was supporting us
when it came out at all.
PAUL SCHEER: But I do think that
that is only apparent to us.
I could say to
you, something that
was a total-- it's the
Donald Trump of it all.
You just say it was successful.
Like yeah, "Wet Hot American
Summer" was a huge hit.
They're like, yeah, it was.
All of a sudden, no
one questions it.
Like, no one looks--
only you know the secret.
Because you could be like,
"Wet Hot" was a giant hit,
and then the sequel came,
and then that was it.
And we shot it for $15 million.
DAVID WAIN: Well in fact,
I have had experiences
where we've tried to
get projects going,
and people were
excited because, oh,
the guys who did "Wet
Hot American Summer."
But then the actual
companies that
want to hire us, we go
down the road with them.
Because they're
like, this is great,
you know, the
classic comedy maker.
And then they went
and actually looked
at the numbers,
which are public,
and they've cut the project off.
They're like, oh, we didn't
know it was a bomb, goodbye.
Pass.
PAUL SCHEER: But
it's so funny though,
because it's not a
bomb if people see it.
Even on this podcast I do,
"How Did This Get Made?",
we did a thing about
"Teen Witch," thank you.
JONATHAN STERN: I do
sincerely love that podcast.
PAUL SCHEER: Thank you.
DAVID WAIN: I'm also
applauding podcasts.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah, podcasts.
We did a thing about "Teen
Witch," and "Teen Witch"
is this giantly popular movie.
It was only released
in 17 theaters,
but it played on
HBO like, nonstop.
So that's how people know it.
So it's like, you
can't just judge it
by who saw it at the time.
Certain things I
like, I don't know--
"MacGruber" is, I think, one
of the funniest movies ever,
but it made no money
at the box office.
It's not indicative of
quality, it's just like--
DAVID WAIN: No, it's a classic.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah.
JONATHAN STERN: Well now
you've identified the dichotomy
in all platforms now.
Which is there's not a
one-to-one comparison
between how many
people see something,
and how much money it makes.
And that used to be more direct.
You might have that, if
everyone saw everything just
by buying it and downloading
it off of iTunes.
But that's not the case.
DAVID WAIN: And one of the great
examples in our world right
now is the state
of Comedy Central.
Which has all these shows that
are huge in the zeitgeist,
and hugely talked
about and loved,
and kind of steering
comedy in many ways.
And nobody watches them.
They have no ratings.
JONATHAN STERN: Well, they don't
watch them on Comedy Central.
80% of the people--
"Portlandia," for example--
I did a series with
IFC, and I found out
that, I think 80% of the
people who watch "Portlandia"
watch it on Netflix.
So everyone knows "Portlandia,"
everyone loves it.
Netflix is getting
lots of people up--
DAVID WAIN: And
80% of the people
who watch "Key and Peele,"
watch it on YouTube.
JONATHAN STERN: Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
They also watch in in clips
and segments on YouTube.
PAUL SCHEER: But that's one of
the things for us, Aziz and Rob
and I, we always are bummed
out because we have this thing,
like "Human Giant,"
which is like,
we are the only ones that--
we have these hard drives.
We these clips, but
because-- I mean,
that's the bummer of
YouTube-- sorry, guys--
that there are those
copyright robots that
are taking stuff down.
Because you want to
get it out there.
Copyright sucks
sometimes, I don't know.
I have nothing more to
say about them then that.
It sucks, because it's like, you
want to go back and watch like,
"Battle of the Network Stars"--
DAVID WAIN: I thought that
was a nuanced argument
about the complexities
of copyrighting.
That was interesting
PAUL SCHEER: Come on.
Because like I said, I
guess the other thing too
is, who are you taking the
money out of if someone
can't watch a clip from a
1972 Johnny Carson appearance?
Who's not making a shitload
of money from that?
I guarantee you--
DAVID WAIN: The Carson
Estate was going
to sell a DVD to that guy.
PAUL SCHEER: I'm a big believer
in just getting your stuff out
there in the best
way that you can,
like in the most accessible way.
And I think that that's what's
been great about YouTube,
for the most part.
And when you sneak it in
and you can watch stuff.
I was able to watch the
"Star Wars Christmas Special"
on YouTube, which is great.
George Lucas wants to
destroy every copy of that.
I was psyched that I was able to
watch it in two long-ass parts.
We need that.
We need to have the ability to
go and watch our huge mistakes,
along with our giant successes.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: How else will
we learn no to repeat them?
PAUL SCHEER: Exactly.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: We'll take
audience questions in a moment,
if anyone wants to line up.
So you all have some
new projects coming out.
Well, one isn't new,
it's continuing,
"Children's Hospital."
JONATHAN STERN: Yes, the seventh
season of "Children's Hospital"
is currently up on Adult Swim,
Friday nights at 11:00 PM.
DAVID WAIN: Every Friday
night is a new episode.
PAUL SCHEER: With Ken Marino.
DAVID WAIN: Ken Marino's in it.
JONATHAN STERN: Yeah.
Paul and I created a show called
"Filthy, Preppy Teens," that
goes up on a new SVOD site
that's about to launch,
called Fullscreen.
It goes up sometime
in the spring.
PAUL SCHEER: Hopefully.
We'll see.
JONATHAN STERN: We
finished it a while ago.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah.
They were about launching
every five minutes.
They're like, next month
we're launching, great.
Two years later, we'll see.
DAVID WAIN: It's the startups
here in Silicon Valley.
JONATHAN STERN:
There are definitely
some projects we can't
announce, including
one kind of high-profile
reboot that we'll
announce in a few weeks.
You're not part of
that one, sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID WAIN: I'm going to
be in the second season
of "Another Period,"
which comes out next year.
JONATHAN STERN: Oh yeah.
PAUL SCHEER: Next year?
DAVID WAIN: A
Comedy Central show.
Or sometime-- thisyear.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah,
I imagine this year.
This year you started.
I have a new show that I
created with The Lonely Island
on FOX, that starts airing
next Saturday night.
It's going to be
from 11:00 to 11:30.
It's a new sketch comedy show
with a Nicole Byer, Jessica
McKenna and Allison Rich.
So it should be fun I hope.
DAVID WAIN: Fine, I'll tape the
news, and then I'll watch that.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First of all, what's
your new show called?
PAUL SCHEER: Oh, it's
called "Party Over Here."
AUDIENCE: Thanks,
thanks for coming.
PAUL SCHEER: Thank
you for reminding me
of that giant part of
advertising my own show.
Yeah-- I should
tell you the title.
I should tell you
the title of it.
AUDIENCE: How else am I going
to search for it on YouTube?
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So what
I was hoping you
guys could give us
some advice on is-- me
and a bunch of my friends
try and write comedy.
And there's a big group of
Googlers that do it as well.
JONATHAN STERN: His
name's Neil, you said?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry?
JONATHAN STERN: His name's Neil?
You said your--
PAUL SCHEER: She
didn't say any names.
AUDIENCE: Oh no, just
me and my friends.
JONATHAN STERN: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: There's a
big group of Googlers
as well, that do these
types of projects.
And for people who don't have
your type of clout, how would
you recommend getting viewers?
Getting people who
want to go on YouTube
and check out your stuff?
Or listen to podcasts of
people they don't know?
What's your ground
zero for starting
with internet-based comedy?
PAUL SCHEER: You know, I
have a quick answer for that,
ultimately.
Which is just, you have
to just do what you like,
and what you think is funny.
And hopefully people
will find that.
Like when we were doing "Human
Giant" in the very beginning.
We had no clout, Aziz had
no clout, I had no clout.
But we made these videos,
we were putting them up.
And then that got word
of mouth, and then
some executives saw it, and
that helped us get the show.
There's a podcast-- this is a
good example of the podcast.
I do this podcast, "How
Did This Get Made?",
and someone's like,
oh my God, you guys
need to listen to
"The Worst Idea Ever."
And it was just a tweet
that was sent to me.
And "The Worst Idea Ever"
is these two Australian guys
who decided to watch "Grown
Ups 2" every week for 52 weeks.
And it's kind of their
descent into madness.
They'd just finished doing "Sex
and the City 2" for a year.
And they go insane,
because they have
to talk about the same
movie week after week,
and it's hilarious.
But someone tweeted at
me-- the concept of it
was funny enough that
I listened to it.
And then I talked about
it on an interview
that I did in The
Onion, and then they
got these tons of
listeners from that.
Because I think people are still
engaged on that same level,
and they've kind of used that.
So I feel like, if you
make something that's good,
and you feel like you're
passionate about it,
and you're not just waiting,
just don't make one thing.
Make a bunch of things,
keep on making things,
and then someone
somewhere will see it.
And that will lead to the
next thing, the next thing,
and the next thing.
There's no short
cut, I feel like.
Just collaborate and work with
people that you really life.
DAVID WAIN: And I agree with
the part about don't wait.
Just do it, make the next thing,
then write the next thing.
Don't be like, oh, I've
got this one thing,
if only somebody
would finance it.
Or if only people would discover
us and give us the work,
or give us the money.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah.
DAVID WAIN: Don't think in
term-- I'd say, just make it.
Just to give some
perspective, I'm 46 years old.
JONATHAN STERN: What?
DAVID WAIN: Thank you.
PAUL SCHEER: You really
have been in this business
for 30 years.
DAVID WAIN: When I
was in high school,
I was making videos
all the time.
And I was excited, but
there was literally
no possible technical chance
that anyone would ever
see them, no matter what.
JONATHAN STERN:
They're all up now.
DAVID WAIN: They're all up now.
But the fact that we do have
this incredible democracy
that people can watch
anything they want,
any time, from anywhere, it's
really-- gives you that chance.
And then, I agree, word of
mouth can spread at any time,
in any way.
And that's very exciting.
And also, if the
means of production
are available to everyone.
You can have a good
quality camera and editing
equipment without spending
any money, it's great.
JONATHAN STERN: What
I learned from David,
and in that first
season of "Wainy Days,"
is not to the half-ass it
when you're doing anything.
Because you don't
know what suddenly
everyone is going to watch.
And if you do
half-ass it, well then
it's not going to go anywhere.
Or if it does, it's not
going to reflect well on you.
DAVID WAIN: And it'll be
on the internet forever.
JONATHAN STERN: Yes.
Don't let the money decide.
Don't say, oh, it's
low budget, so I'm just
going to do a mediocre job.
What you're doing is
being put out there.
No one cares how much
money you spent on it.
But also, if there's one secret,
apparently just email Paul
and get him to tweet about it.
DAVID WAIN: But I have
to say, I can't tell you
how many people have contacted
me anonymously and said, hey,
I'd love you to watch
this video I made.
I mean, it's not great
because I didn't really--
I rushed through it, and I
didn't bother editing it down,
or the sound sucks,
and I didn't really
write it very carefully
because I didn't have time.
And I mean it's like, no,
I'm not going to watch that.
PAUL SCHEER: The
other thing too is,
you can track anyone's
success to one thing,
where someone discovered
them or something.
So it's always like that.
But when you do
have that moment,
I think what Jon saying
is, then if they look back
on your other stuff, it
should be on the same level.
Then you have a
reason for people
to continue, and not be the
"Gangnam Style" of comedy,
that one hit and it's over.
DAVID WAIN: Although,
have you seen that?
It's so funny.
Gangnam style!
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah
yeah, he's a funny guy.
DAVID WAIN: It's a video.
JONATHAN STERN:
You showed it to me
literally 50 times in
the "Children's Hospital"
writer's room.
DAVID WAIN: Have you
seen this, though?
It's on YouTube,
I'll show it to you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVID WAIN: Www.YouTube--
JONATHAN STERN: You can say
goodbye when you're done.
PAUL SCHEER: She said thank you!
DAVID WAIN: Here
comes someone who
is either returning from the
bathroom, or has a question.
PAUL SCHEER: No,
she was getting up.
JONATHAN STERN:
Maybe the question
is, where's the bathroom?
PAUL SCHEER: It's weird they
put the bathroom right behind us
on stage.
AUDIENCE: Hi, guys.
PAUL SCHEER: Hi!
AUDIENCE: Thanks for being here.
I'm a huge fan of all
of your many things.
There's a lot of them,
you've got a lot of credits,
and we don't have a lot of time.
I want to know what your--
JONATHAN STERN: We have time
if you want to list them.
PAUL SCHEER: No.
AUDIENCE: All of the
things with "hot"
in them, "Wet Hot,"
"Hotwives," "NTSF,"
et cetera, colon, colon--
JONATHAN STERN: "Burning
Love," also on Hulu.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
PAUL SCHEER: Let her
ask her question.
AUDIENCE: I want to know
what your favorite thing is
that you've done?
I'm so sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID WAIN: I really--
I always heard people
say this when I was a kid.
People I was fans of, and I
thought it was such bullshit.
But now that I am where I am, at
this time in my life, I guess,
it's not bullshit to me.
I don't really look
back that way so much.
So I'm very excited about
what I'm doing right now.
And maybe what I just
did, but it's weird.
I'm speaking for myself, I love
all the things that I've done.
And I'm very proud of
it, and if I do see it,
or people talk about it,
I'm psyched and thrilled
that people like it.
But I don't know, I sort of
disconnect in a certain way,
though, and I'm most
jazzed about what
I'm currently working on.
JONATHAN STERN: So you're
just speaking for yourself,
you said?
Because that seems
self-evident, at that point.
DAVID WAIN: Right, I should
have-- that was obvious.
Sometimes you have
to underline it.
PAUL SCHEER: I do think it's
tough to kind of narrow down,
like, that was my
favorite thing.
Because I think
we're lucky enough
to continue to work with
really great people.
We've all worked together,
and I think the relationships,
and the times-- I can
pinpoint one great moment
on every project.
I think every now and then
I'm surprised to get money
to do something, and those
are fun, weird victories.
Like when I met
with this guy, he
was like, whatever you
want to do, we have money.
Doesn't matter how weird
it is, and I'm like,
oh I'd like to re-enact old
episodes of "The Arsenio Hall
Show," and do that,
word-for-word.
And he was like, great.
And then all of a sudden,
someone built the set
and we were shooting it, and I
was dressed like Aresnio Hall.
That, to me, was amazing.
And only better then that I got
invited on "The Arsenio Hall
Show" as Arsenio Hall, to
sit with Arsenio Hall-- who
didn't even get the joke
that I was Arsenio Hall!
So that culmination
of that one thing
was so crazy, because that
was something that was never
an idea that I
would pitch, never
an idea that I would chase down.
But someone was like, what's
the craziest idea that you want?
And I was like, this.
And then he was like, great.
Then that led to-- and then
what I love about that too,
is that's something that you
can't monetize or put out
in any other way.
Where is there a
market for recreations
of Arsenio Hall's talk show?
Nowhere.
So it was great, it's on
YouTube, it's awesome.
And I did it again for
Carson Daly, for TRL.
It just exists in this
thing, and I think
that that's really fun too.
To be able to try things
for different media.
Not to be like, not everything
has to be a TV show,
not everything has to
be a movie or anything.
So that was really fun.
And again, to meet
Arsenio Hall and for him
to tell me backstage,
hey man-- I
think he thought I was a kid who
did this in my basement-- like,
keep it up.
You come out here to
Hollywood and opportunities
will be open to you.
I was like, all right.
You realize, that some of the
people in this Arsenio thing
were like, Seth Rogen,
Max Greenfield-- I
got some big celebrities.
And then he was like, yeah
man, keep it up, keep it up.
I said, all right, I will.
JONATHAN STERN: I'd say anything
I've done over the last five
years, I've really enjoyed.
Literally joyful going
to set, being part of it.
Prior to that was
ups and downs, a lot
of really stressful
situations a lot of times,
that I was saying, I'm never
going to do this again.
DAVID WAIN: I say
that every time.
JONATHAN STERN: Yeah.
But similar to your story
about ArScheerio Paul,
there's a 4:00 AM
slot on Adult Swim
that the head of Adult
Swim calls "DVR Theater."
And we and my company
do a bunch of these,
sometimes fake infomercials, or
just short films or weird shit,
that goes up, they're quarter
hours, there's no advertising.
We get a tiny budget and no one
is looking over our shoulder.
Did one with Paul, "Hotel TV."
PAUL SCHEER: The
one that we did was,
the TV turned into
a hotel TV screen,
and it was like,
select menu, this.
And it just became like
you were in a hotel,
and it clearly-- it became very
clear the hotel was haunted
by Indians who were
trying to kill you
for gambling on their land.
And it was hosted by Ray
Wise from "Twin Peaks."
It was the most insane
thing, again, up on YouTube.
JONATHAN STERN: We
just shot last week,
one with Rob Huebel that's
all fake news fails.
And one with Showalter that's
kind of a Winnebago man thing.
We did a series
called "You're Whole,"
starring Michael Ian Black.
And a million people watch
these at four in the morning,
because, I think,
nothing else is on.
But it's such a bubble.
What Paul said about
ArScheerio Paul,
OK, do whatever you want to do.
Because the stakes are so
low for this particular time
slot and project.
PAUL SCHEER: It's the
closest thing to art.
It's whatever you want to do.
There's no parameters.
You don't have to fit
in any box at all.
DAVID WAIN: I felt
that way when we
were doing our
"Stella" shorts, which
were for literally nobody.
I mean, we showed
them at a nightclub
with about this many
people every week,
and thought that was the last
that we would hear from it.
But then we didn't know
the internet would still
be going at this point.
But I have often thought
that the fun and enjoyment
of doing something is an inverse
relationship to the budget.
JONATHAN STERN: I.e, the steaks.
DAVID WAIN: I love steak.
PAUL SCHEER: Donald Trump
steaks, did you see this?
JONATHAN STERN: What?
PAUL SCHEER: He had a line
of steaks available only
at Sharper Image.
I learned that from "The
John Oliver Show" this week,
it was amazing.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a question?
I mean this in the most
endearing way possible.
JONATHAN STERN: Uh oh.
AUDIENCE: That's not the
best way to start, right?
But--
DAVID WAIN: We're out of
time, is that what it is?
AUDIENCE: You guys do
some really weird stuff.
And I'm just curious,
especially for having done it
for so long, how do you feel
like your comedy tastes,
and what you guys have
tried to experiment
with has changed or grown
over all of the years
that you've been doing it?
And I'm going to sit down.
DAVID WAIN: I could say
that my taste in comedy
has changed surprisingly little.
And my, what you would
call sensibility I guess,
has changed very little from
what I was even like, 12.
And particularly--
it's just interesting,
I think that might be
a good thing somehow.
Something locked in about
what makes sense to me.
And then I've evolved
how I do things,
and I've evolved the craft
and the many, many things
around it.
But the actual, your
question, I don't know
if it's changed all that much.
PAUL SCHEER: I think that's
one of the cool things
about everything
that you do, though.
It's in the vein of
a Woody Allen thing.
DAVID WAIN: It's infantile.
PAUL SCHEER: No, but
you always know--
JONATHAN STERN: It's like
locked in a box in time.
PAUL SCHEER: But
I think that there
are a handful of
directors that you know,
and writers and performers.
But you have such a
distinctive stamp on stuff.
I love what you do, but it's
so unlike anybody else's stuff.
And even on something that
is a bigger, mainstream
stuff that you did,
like "Role Models,"
it still feels like
a David Wain movie.
And I think that that's
a very hard thing to do.
Especially with this new voice
of all these big budget movies.
It's hard to be like,
oh, that's a blank movie,
or that's a blank movie.
It's much like--
DAVID WAIN: And particularly,
because comedies today so often
are written by huge
numbers of people
that all toss in at
different points.
And without some
strong voice taking it
from beginning to end,
that's the trap I think,
that can happen.
JONATHAN STERN: This is
a great point for you.
And yes, one of-- I think--
your extreme strengths.
It's the commitment
you have to your voice,
and how people recognize it.
Now you see people pick up, oh,
I'm doing a David Wain thing.
We can't help ourselves, when
we're in the writers room,
starting to make
David Wain jokes
and we're called out on it.
But that specificity
of voice is something
that you have the
opportunity to do when
you're doing your own project.
And my own personal advice is
rather than trying emulate some
other style and say, hey I'm
doing a "Seinfeld"-type show.
If this is your opportunity--
and hopefully not
your only opportunity in your
life-- but to do something
that is so specifically
your voice.
And that's what gets it
out there more than, great,
you did a great job of
sounding like the big boys.
DAVID WAIN: Although
on the other hand,
so many great artists
and musicians,
and anyone that I
follow-- you start often
by imitating your
favorite people.
And then over time, your
particular thing emerges.
I mean for me, it was
always there, but you know--
PAUL SCHEER: But to answer your
question too, I feel like--
DAVID WAIN: Just kidding.
PAUL SCHEER: --for
me, I definitely
had things that I love.
And I still love those
things-- when I first
started enjoying comedy.
But then I think my taste--
when I got to college,
and I went to NYU, my tastes
kind of opened up a little bit.
We all went to NYU,
all three of us.
But I feel like that opened
my worldview a little bit.
And I think the one
thing that I'm always
conscious of--
there's two things.
One, to always watch
stuff of new stuff.
I feel like that's the quickest
way to feel or get older,
get stagnant, is not keeping up
on what is currently out there.
Right now, "Broad City"
is my favorite show.
I think that's so amazing
and they're great.
I love that, but
I'm not like a guy
that-- I feel like I've run
into a handful of people who've
achieved a certain
status and they
kind of wall themselves
off into their own world.
And I think that's a problem.
And then for me, I think I want
to challenge myself to always
be like, all right, I've done
that, now let me do this.
Let me try this.
So I always am trying
to self regulate.
Like, I've done something
like that, let me do this now.
And also not tread
the same ground.
I always go back and
do something weird,
like Hotel TV or
something like that.
But I also, for the long
term, I want to make sure
that's not repeating a pattern.
And I think to your
credit, that's something
that you do really well.
You keep your voice consistent,
but your projects very varied.
DAVID WAIN: It's just fueled
by getting bored really easily.
And I know that if I went
back, and do something that's
not interesting to me
because I did it before,
I will be miserable.
JONATHAN STERN: I remember
once a few years ago, it
was between projects,
and you said,
I'm going to take a month
off and just get input.
See plays, read, do whatever.
Which had never occurred to
me as a practical use of time
before.
And of course, it's a
super smart thing to do.
PAUL SCHEER: I do that at
the end of every big project.
It's the best time to
be like, and now I'm
going to just like veg out
and just suck in everything
that you can possibly do.
Because you need that,
you need to be inspired.
I saw "Hamilton," and it was one
of the best things I've seen.
Movie, TV, anything--
DAVID WAIN: It's the
best thing that's
happened in the arts
in the last 10 years.
PAUL SCHEER: And I feel like
you need to see stuff like that.
Because I may not be
making a rap musical,
but just seeing someone
reenvision a form of Broadway
is like, oh, that's inspiring.
It's invigorating, it's
a very energizing thing
to let other people's
amazing ideas inspire you.
DAVID WAIN: And the truth is,
the last thing I tend to watch
is comedy of any kind.
I get inspired by and
entertained by things that
don't feel like I'm at work.
PAUL SCHEER: I agree,
comedy is probably
lower on my list of things to
watch, besides "Family Feud."
You gotta watch that.
Steve Harvey is a genius!
DAVID WAIN: And
"Nathan For You."
PAUL SCHEER: Oh, "Nathan
For You" is so great.
JONATHAN STERN: But
that's beyond comedy.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Well,
thank you all so much
for joining us today.
We look forward to seeing
all of your various projects,
and the next evolution
of your work.
DAVID WAIN: Thank you, Dana.
This has been awesome.
JONATHAN STERN: Dana!
PAUL SCHEER: Thank
you, everybody.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]